[Música]
la actualidad más destacada del
continente africano está en France 24
Bienvenidos a África siete días estos
son los titulares el ciclón Freddy ha
cobrado la vida de más de 500 personas
en el sur de África La mayoría de ellas
en malaui este país sin salida al mar
uno de los más empobrecidos del mundo se
enfrenta ahora a una posible crisis
humanitaria según Naciones Unidas
Estados Unidos quiere aumentar su
presencia en el Ángel para contrarrestar
la creciente influencia rusa en la
región reunido con el presidente de
níger Mohamed bazum el secretario de
estado estadounidense posicionó a su
país como mejor socio que Moscú los
detalles en un momento es el plan
insignia del gobierno británico devolver
a sus migrantes y solicitantes de asilo
a Ruanda la ministra británica de
interior suela brei derman estuvo de
visita en kigali la capital orlandesa
para discutir este acuerdo ampliamente
criticado por los activistas de los
derechos humanos y por el momento
bloqueado por la justicia Europea
en el sur de África el ciclón Freddy ha
dejado al menos 570 fallecidos en malawi
mozambique y Madagascar y causó enormes
daños materiales formado a principios de
Febrero en el norte de Australia este
fenómeno que recorrió más de 8000 km de
este a oeste en el océano Índico hasta
el Sur del continente africano fue uno
de los más duraderos y largos jamás
registrados los peores daños se han
visto en malaui tan solo en este país se
registran más de 470 muertos y más de
340 desaparecidos los desplazados llegan
a casi medio millón en la región de
Vampire al sur de malawi en medio de un
paisaje desolador donde las inundaciones
los vientos y los deslizamientos de
tierra lo han arrasado todo el ejército
y los socorristas ya no pueden hacer más
los intentos de rescate terminan ahora
con la recolección de cuerpos en
descomposición el olor a putre facción y
las Burbujas de agua que suben a la
superficie del suelo embarrado sugieren
que hay cientos de muertos enterrados
los residentes De esta zona dicen que en
todo este lugar había casas por lo tanto
es un poco difícil dar un número
estimado que hay muchas personas
enterradas aquí
para ayudar a los equipos de rescate y
acelerar la búsqueda de los más de 340
desaparecidos las autoridades han
enviado perros rastreadores y han
reiterado su petición de ayuda
internacional
mientras hablo algunas zonas siguen
siendo inaccesibles por carretera e
incluso en barco el gobierno de zambia a
través de su fuerza aérea enviará
aviones mañana
uno de estos aviones carga ayuda
humanitaria para malawi y otro es un
helicóptero que se utilizará para
acceder a las zonas inaccesibles Aunque
la ONU ha destinado 5,5 millones de
dólares para los afilados en malawi la
ayuda humanitaria llega a cuentagotas
las ongs temen que la atención de los
donantes siga centrada en otras crisis
como Ucrania o Turquía unos
supervivientes se han instalado en esta
escuela convertida en un refugio de
emergencia después de que un
deslizamiento de tierra arrasara sus
casas
necesitamos comida ropa y sábanas es
difícil sobrevivir sin comida y si es
posible necesitaríamos encontrar un
lugar donde poder construir Nuevas Casas
además mientras el estado de catástrofe
fue declarado en el país las ong
advierten del riesgo de que se agrave la
epidemia de cólera que ya hacía estragos
antes de la llegada del ciclón según los
especialistas es entre otras cosas el
calentamiento de los océanos lo que
contribuye a la intensificación de los
ciclones fenómenos que aparecen varias
veces al año en el suroeste del océano
Índico pero cuya frecuencia va en
aumento
Por fin en libertad el periodista
francés
estuvo retenido durante
711 días en el sahel por un grupo armado
el 8 de abril de 2021 fue secuestrado en
gao al norte de Mali Donde había ido a
entrevistar a un líder yihadista en un
vídeo publicado en las redes sociales el
5 de mayo de 2021 el periodista confirmó
que estaba en manos del grupo de apoyo
al islam y a los musulmanes una alianza
ya lista delzaje vinculada al caida el
presidente francés Emmanuel majó
agradeció a las autoridades de níger
donde apareció libre por su ayuda para
la liberación
escuchemos las primeras reacciones de
Olivia a su llegada al aeropuerto de
ñame capital de níger es un poco
impresionante con todos estos micrófonos
yo soy el que suele tener el micrófono
no solo quería decir que obviamente es
enorme para mí estar aquí ser libre no
me lo esperaba Quería rendir homenaje a
níger y a su saber hacer en este tipo de
misiones dedicadas y rendir homenaje a
Francia y a todos los que me han
permitido estar hoy aquí y tras más de
seis años de secuestro el estadounidense
Jeffrey también fue dejado en libertad
junto a Olivia este cooperante
humanitario había sido secuestrado en
níger en octubre de 2016 por grupos
yadistas y llevado a Mali
Estados Unidos tiene más que ofrecer a
la región africana del sahel que Moscú
Esta es una declaración inequívoca del
secretario de estado estadounidense
Anthony blinken que estuvo en níger un
país que se enfrenta a numerosos retos
entre ellos La amenaza del terrorismo y
la inestabilidad política en la región
además de ser uno de los focos de la
rivalidad que mantiene Estados Unidos
con China y Rusia por la influencia
sobre el continente africano
Y por qué nafasó dos países con los que
Niger comparte frontera han sufrido
recientes golpes de estado y siguen bajo
gobiernos militares mientras la
violencia yadista sigue cobrándose
víctimas Anthony blinken dijo querer
ayudar a níger y confirmó un nuevo
paquete de ayuda financiera para el país
es el primer jefe de la diplomacia
estadounidense en visitar Antonio
blinquen secretario de estado de la
nación norteamericana se reunió con el
presidente nigerino mohamedún antes de
ofrecer una rueda de prensa conjunta con
hatsumi masedu ministro de asuntos
exteriores las fuerzas de Estados Unidos
siguen teniendo una base aérea en níger
Desde allí pueden vigilar y atacar a los
yihadistas Y es que el país sigue a su
lado por la violencia de grupos armados
afiliados a al qaeda o el autodenominado
estado islámico para hacer frente a esta
creciente amenaza Washington ha
anunciado una ayuda adicional de 150
millones de dólares con lo que el total
ascenderá a 233 millones para 2023
brinquen dice que todo el mundo deberá
ser utilizado para contener el aumento
de la violencia
el ministro habló de nuestra inversión
total en estos proyectos que también son
muy importantes para evitar que la gente
se vuelva extremista o terrorista y hay
proyectos por valor de cientos de
millones de dólares
para occidente Francia y Estados Unidos
en particular níger es un país Aliado
para Washington Esta visita es una
manera de afianzar su posición en el
sahel sobre todo tras el acercamiento de
los vecinos malienses y burkineses a
Moscú y su colaboración militar con el
grupo paramilitar ruso Wagner
allá donde va Wagner suelen ocurrir
cosas malas en primer lugar allí donde
les hemos visto actuar no ha mejorado la
seguridad al contrario hemos visto cómo
empeoraron las cosas la explotación de
los recursos y la corrupción la
violencia que este grupo engendra es una
epidemia que se está extendiendo entre
la población de los países que han
decidido trabajar con mercados
tras la secretaria del tesoro la
embajadora de Estados Unidos ante la ONU
linda Tomás grimmel y la primera dama
Gil biden el viaje de blinken fue la
cuarta visita a África de de un alto
cargo del gobierno estadounidense
desde kingali la capital ruandés a la
ministra británica de interior suela
braderman ha defendido el polémico
acuerdo alcanzado hace casi un año para
deportar a Ruanda a los migrantes que
llegan al Reino Unido a través del Canal
de la Mancha el proyecto es denunciado
por muchas organizaciones de Derechos
Humanos pero Londres y creen que podría
convertirse en un modelo a seguir
lo que queremos es crear soluciones
innovadoras para poder ofrecer a estos
solicitantes de asilo y migrantes
seguridad protección y la oportunidad de
llevar una vida digna
Life
trabajaremos con el Reino Unido para
ofrecer esta solución sabemos que se
trata de una solución nueva y seguimos
supervisando su aplicación
estamos dispuestos a adaptarla y
Esperamos que otros países se unan a
nosotros Cuando vean la solución
funciona
[Música]
a finales del año pasado vimos morir a
personas en el Canal de la Mancha en su
infortunado intento de llegar a Reino
Unido Por eso creo que existe una
oportunidad real de reubicar a las
personas en entornos seguros y
protegidos donde puedan llevar una vida
próspera y saludable por eso estoy muy
entusiasmada con este acuerdo Creo que
será un modelo para otros países en el
futuro
el tribunal europeo de Derechos Humanos
lleva meses bloqueando el acuerdo Sin
embargo a principios de enero la
justicia británica aceptó revisarlo en
apelación
y seguimos en chigaly sede del Congreso
número 73 de la FIFA donde fue elegido
para un segundo mandato Jean infantino
hasta 2027 como presidente de la
federación deportiva cargo que ocupa
desde 2016 una reelección sin oposición
y aclamada nuestra corresponsal María
nos cuenta más
es imparte gracias a África un
continente con 54 federaciones y por
tanto uno de los más votados que
infantino ha podido reivindicar un nuevo
mandato como el presidente de la FIFA
para comprender el papel desempeñado por
el continente africano en esta
reelecciones ya que remontarse dos años
atrás cuando
numerosos países africanos de Marruecos
a burundi para reunirse con sus
presidentes con el fin de asegurarse su
apoyo hoy Gracias a esta estrategia el
hombre poco apreciado por las
federaciones
del Norte ha podido asegurarse un según
mandato con la ayuda de este continente
Kelly mismo se refiere como el futuro
del Fútbol El Congreso de la FIFA es
normalmente una oportunidad para los
miembros discutan para que los miembros
discutan las propuestas de las distintas
federaciones este año la delegación
noruegas pidió a la FIFA una evaluación
de los muertos en las obras del mundial
de 2022 en Qatar en una indemnización
para las familias de las víctimas así
como el pago de los salarios de más de
30,000 trabajadores en su mayoría
inmigrantes de Asia y África durante
esta reunión Se abordó la cuestión pero
no se dio ninguna respuesta
la ciudad marfile Leña de avión acogió
la edición número 16 de la afric Fashion
week una cita imprescindible en el
calendario de la moda africana en torno
al tema juventud moda y diversidad
cultural 30 diseñadores de moda de
varios países estuvieron presentes para
presentar sus creaciones les dejamos con
imágenes del desfile Gracias por
acompañarnos la actualidad internacional
continúa en France 24 y Francia 24.com
[Música]